. . . . . . . . . . . Hey, the coolest guy is in town. Das ist das Podcast-UFO, das ist dasgelastet. Und jetzt können wir uns eine Stunde lang anhören, was er in seinem tollen Leben mit seinen tollen Freunden gemacht hat. Im tollen Italien und das Wetter war ja so toll. Da haben wir uns so ein schönes Cabriolet gemietet und am Strand die Riviera entlang. Und wir wussten auch nicht, wo wir am nächsten Tag sein werden. Wir fahren einfach durch die Gegend. Komm, zeig deine scheiß Dias und lass uns dann teilhaben, wie toll du bist. Wo ist das Fall langgegangen mit diesen Dias? Ich erinnere mich aus meiner Kindheit an so viele Dias-Shows. Keine. Von die So-und-Sos waren in Afrika, die haben jetzt ihre Dia-Shows. Aber es waren auch nur so zwei Wochen, wo man die hatte und dann waren die weg wieder. Ja, aber eigentlich eine geile Sache, weil es hat schon so ein grosser Beamer und dann immer dieses Klack und du weißt nicht, was da vorkommt und was danach kommt. Und man kann immer selber entscheiden, wie lange man bei einer Dia bleibt. Irgendwann wurde das ja abgelöst von Direkt iPhoto. Es kam direkt die iCloud. Es kam direkt iPhoto mit diesem generischen Song, den einfach jeder schon tausendmal gehört hat, wo jedes Bild nur drei Sekunden da war. Und auch oft Screenshots von Dingen, die man gemacht hat, wo man jetzt nicht wollte, dass Leute das sehen. Irgendwie Hemorridencreme, Meinungen und sowas, so Tapsoffen. Genau, und die Familien-Whatsapp-Gruppe, wo dann noch irgendwie diese peinlichen Bilder sind von der Herbert, Bert im Wald und du hast nicht genug Zeit, das durchzulesen. Und so weiter. Und man erzählt schon über ein Bild und die Show ist schon drei Bilder weiter und man... Ist schon im anderen Urlaub, schon in 90 Italien. Und man guckt nur langsam dabei zu, wie diese ganze Präsentation in sich zusammenfällt. Das war eigentlich auch schön. Ja, war auch schön. Nee, ich war, ähm, du hast viele Sachen auch gezählt. Wo warst du denn jetzt? Erzähl doch mal. Ich war in Norditalien, mit dem Ort rumgefahren mit Freunden. Aber jetzt nicht so wie du meinst, dieses, weil das ist ein schmaler Grat. Ich finde, es ist ein schmaler Grat zwischen sympathischem Urlaub und unsympathischem Urlaub. Und dieses, man weiss ja gar nicht, wo man landet und so. Tut mir leid, aber das ist bei mir, wenn das Leute sagen, erst mal unsympathischer Aspekt. Es ist spezifisch geplant worden von einem der Freunde, das ist auch wichtig, dass man eine gute Gruppe hat, weil man selber will ja nichts planen. Man selber will ja nur die Lorbeeren abstauben. Die Kirsche auf der, sagt man die Lorbeeren, ich weiß nicht, die Kirsche auf der Sahnetorte des Urlaubs, willst du ja nur essen. Richtig. So, du willst halt quasi Urlaub machen, aber andere sollen planen. Genau. Andere sollen mit den Airbnb-Hosts kommunizieren. Andere sollen packen. Andere sollen für mich packen. Andere sollen meinen Koffer packen. Andere sollen mich mit Sonnencreme einschmieren. Andere sollen mir den Drink an die Lippen führen. Andere sollen sich die ganze Zeit Gedanken machen, habe ich jetzt richtig mit dem Airbnb-Host kommuniziert, wann wir ankommen, wo wir ankommen? Habe ich das richtig übersetzt? Andere sollen mein Sudoku machen. Ich reiche denen das Heft und die machen am Pool Sudoku für mich. Andere sollen mein Buch lesen. Andere sollen Italienisch sprechen. Ich komme gar nicht mit. Ich bleibe zu Hause, andere fahren für mich in Urlaub. Sollen für mich in Urlaub fahren. Das Ding ist, und wir hatten so jemanden in der Gruppe. Und das war perfekt. Der ist auch noch Koch und hat die besten Restaurants ausgesucht. Da kann ich echt verstehen, warum du nie mit mir in Urlaub wirst, weil deine anderen Freunde so viel besser sind. Ich verstehe das ja, ich würde es ja nicht anders machen. Nee, ich denke mir das auch. Deswegen habe ich das auch jetzt gemacht, mich von dir abgesondert. Weil du bist ja jemand, du bist ja wie ich im Urlaub sein will, organisier es nicht. Echt, genau. Wir sind uns so ähnlich, was das angeht dir bin ich ja der Airbnb, der mit dem Airbnb-Haus kommuniziert und sich irgendwann im Ton vergreift und deswegen mussten wir in New York auf der Strasse schlafen. Das sind halt die Dinge, die wollen wir halt vermeiden. Deswegen brauchen wir halt Leute, die das für uns machen. Erwachsene brauchen wir. Wir brauchen erwachsene Anwälte neben uns. Ja, wir brauchen Leute, die sich drum kümmern, um alles, woran wir nicht mal denken. Nee, es war fantastisch. Italien ist schon toll, die wissen, wie man lebt. Ah, bella Italia, Dolce Vito, un poco Mozzarelli e Spaghetti. Spaghetti, i primi secundi. Ich vergiss jedes Mal, wenn ich wieder nach Italien komme, man ist ja häufig in Italien, als Deutschland ist man häufig, du auch gerade aus der Nähe von München, du bist ja häufig in Italien gewesen, wahrscheinlich. Man vergisst ja immer, jedes Mal, dass die zwei Gänge haben. Primi e secondi. Vergess nicht jedes Mal, si claro, certo. Und ich habe so oft Buenos Dias gesagt und gracias und por favor, dass es mir irgendwann echt unangenehm war, weil die merken das ja da habe ich mir gefällt ist italienisch spanisch so ein bisschen wie holländisch deutsch also dass man wenn uns jetzt in den ausländern irgendwie sagen würde keine ahnung danke weil wenn man jetzt nicht aufwendet man beirritiert aber wenn ich da jetzt sitzt und sagt gratias oder ein Vino, por favor, dann ist das ja schon ein bisschen merkwürdig. Aber ich lasse mir, ob ich an Merkwürdigkeitsgale war, war das denn für die Kellner? Ich glaube, die sehen dich, wie du mit deinen Sanderletten da reinkommst, mit deinem Deutschlandhut auf, und die denken sich, egal was aus dem Mund von diesem Mann kommt, es ist einfach erbärmlich und schäbig. Ja, aber Gott sei Dank ist es nicht deutsch. Weil sie mich in Deutsch vollquatschen, ist ja auch super. Ich habe mal verwechselt, weil ich habe in der Schule Französisch gelernt und dann war ich in Italien und war völlig verwirrt zwischen mehreren Sprachen hin und hergerissen. Und dann wollte ich ein Eis bestellen, habe ich gesagt, una gelato sibuplari. Sibuplari. Sibuplari. Und das war einfach, der Eisverkäufer hat nicht mit der Wim gezogen und hat einfach nichts. Ich glaube, das interessiert die nicht. Da ist eh nur so, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop. Aber wie gut bei Sibuplari irgendwie so Milchcreme wäre. Ja. Haben wir nicht. Wir haben es nicht ohne Milch. Und ich so ein richtig fancy Eisbecher bekomme den besten. Ich habe den geheimen Eisbecher freigestaltet, kann auch sein. Ah, das Sibuplari. Das war das Wichtigste. Das ist ja das Beste eigentlich.este eigentlich. Dieses Abenteuer Urlauben, wie du es machst, ist mir zu wild. Ich will jedes Jahr an den selben Ort fahren, weil ich will so einen Urlaubsort auch durchspielen. Weil wenn man das zweite Mal da ist, dann kennt man schon die Basics, dann kann man sich direkt auf die Essenz konzentrieren. Und so nach fünfzehn Mal hat man es irgendwann durchgespielt. Zum Beispiel haben wir irgendwann rausgefunden, ich war oft dasselbe Jahr immer in Italien am selben Ort, und irgendwann haben wir die Eisdiele gefunden, die hatte halbe Eiskugeln. Das heißt, du kannst für den Preis von einer Eiskugel zwei verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen haben. Das heißt, du sagst, eine Hälfte bitte mit Fragola, Sivuplari e una Stracciatello Sivuplari. Aber irgendwann haben wir herausgefunden, dass zwei Hälften größer sind als eine Kugel. Was ich gemacht habe, ist, ich bin dann hingegangen und habe gesagt, ich hätte gerne eine Hälfte Vanille gemacht und noch eine Hälfte Vanille. Und es hat jedes Mal geklappt und ich habe mehr Vanille bekommen als alle anderen Kinder. Und dann habt ihr im nächsten Jahr eine Entdeck die Viertelkugel gemacht. Da haben wir gesagt, hier fahren wir immerhin. Jedes Mal hin. Aber das stimmt, ich sehe das ein bisschen so auch so. Also ich habe mehr Wendel bekommen als alle anderen Kinder. Und dann habt ihr im nächsten Jahr eine Entdeckt, die Viertelkuchen gemacht hat. Und dann haben wir gesagt, hier fahren wir immerhin. Jedes Mal hin. Aber das stimmt, ich sehe das ein bisschen so auch so. Also ich habe jetzt sehr viele neue Orte entdeckt, kleine Orte, ganz toll, um mal richtig runterzukommen. Auch diese herrlichen historischen Altstädte auch mal toll. Und die richtigen Trattorien und herrlich. Das war alles herrlich, aber ich verstehe ein bisschen, was du meinst. Ich habe ein, anderes Beispiel, ich habe das immer in sehr guten Hotels, wenn man mal sich was gönnt oder halt aber auch mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwo mal eingeladen wird oder ist man da oder was auch immer. So, dann bist du in einem guten Hotel und dann denke ich mir, jedes Mal, eigentlich sollte ich mir kein gutes Hotel gönnen, weil ich immer denke, habe ich alles genutzt, was ich bezahlt habe. Ich habe immer dieses, und das ist ein bisschen das, was du meinst, wenn du an einen Urlaubsort kommst und dann willst du halt den auch durchspielen. Du willst da alles nutzen, was möglich ist. Du willst aus diesem Ort das Beste machen. Und wenn man in einem guten Hotel ist, denke ich mir, dieser Preis war so extrem, so ich will jetzt aber auch alles nutzen, was hier möglich ist. Und deswegen denke ich mir, eigentlich entweder sollten die mir einen Flyer geben, das kann man hier alles machen. Ach und übrigens, sie können kostenlos einfach im Zimmer frühstücken oder sowas. Oder wenn sie am Tisch noch fragen, ob sie ein Rührei bekommen, dann machen wir das noch frisch. Keine Ahnung, so ein Scheiß. Ich will einfach einen Zettel haben mit allen Dingen, die man machen kann. Und deswegen gehe ich immer in die Rezeption und frage, was kann man hier denn noch so machen. Geben Sie mir eine Liste und abhakbar, was ich alles machen kann. Was ich alles machen kann. Habe ich alles genutzt, was ich bezahlt habe. Du bist ja als Urlauber eigentlich immer in dem ewigen Paradoxon, dass du zwar Tourist bist, aber nicht Tourist sein willst. Nein. Du willst ja möglichst wenig touristisch Urlauber richtig verhalten, also was ist mit den Rutschen, wo sind die, wo muss ich da hin, sondern du willst ja möglichst souverän wirken und möglichst alles wissen, als ob du da arbeiten würdest oder als ob du da leben würdest und muss dann aber immer so diese Gratwanderung gehen.
Deswegen, glaube ich, ist meine Kampfortzone eher häufiger dahin, weil ab dem zweiten Mal bist du kein Tourist mehr.
Du kennst dich dann da so aus und weisst genau, ah, hier die Go-Karts, da kannst du auch die Marken vom Frühstück reinschmeissen.
Das heisst, du kannst anstatt morgens ein Cappuccino nehmen, kannst du einfach die Marke mitnehmen und in die Go-Karts werfen, so dass du da direkt eine Runde mehr fahren kannst als die anderen Kinder. Und dann kannst du schon früher los, weil der Typ, der diese Marken verkauft vom Go-Kart stand, der macht erst um acht Uhr auf, du hast aber deine Cappuccino-Marke schon von sieben Uhr und kannst dann schon auf die Bahn, bevor alle anderen Kinder fahren. Und dann kannst du nämlich nicht mehr aus dem Go-Kart aussteigen, sondern kannst da drin sitzen bleiben, wenn du vom Vortag noch die ganzen Chips gekauft hast, abends, wenn die billiger sind. So, und dann bist du den ganzen Tag im Go-Kart. Auch gut mit der Eins wegen der Verfügung, die du bekommen hast, weil du die ganze Zeit mit Kindern abhängst, dass die Go-Kart-Bahn immer leer ist. Weil die Kinder dürfen dann nicht an mich. Ich habe die Eins wegen der Verfügung, ich darf nicht 150 Meter an Kinder ran. Aber ich sitze ja schon im Go-Kart. Du sitzt schon im Go-Kart, seit sechs Uhr morgen sitzt du schon im Go-Kart, mit deinem Cappuccino-Stipp. Ich habe den Richter gefragt, ja, aber Herr Richter, können mich dann Kinder einfach durch die Gegend scheuchen, wie sie wollen, wenn sie auf mich zulaufen, hat der Richter gesagt, nein, wenn das Kind auf sie zuläuft, kann es auch näher kommen, sie dürfen sich nur nicht in Richtung des Kindes bewegen. Das heisst, wenn ich mit Go-Kart mit rasanter Geschwindigkeit, ich kenne die Strecke, ich kenne den Looping, ich kenne die Bahn um diesen grünen Frosch herum, das Maskottchen
von dem Hotel, ich kenne die Strecke, ich kenne den Looping, ich kenne die Bahn um diesen grünen Frosch herum, Maskottchen von dem Hotel, ich kenne die Strecke mit einer Rasengeschwindigkeit. Und da haben die Kinder schon oft Probleme, die 150 Meter einzuhalten. Ja, prallen die an so einer Invisible Mauer ab? Oder wie läuft das denn konkret, diese 50 Meter Rule? Gibt es das in Deutschland überhaupt? Ist das nicht so eine Legende aus so CSI-Serien oder so? Ich meine schon. Und ich habe irgendwann mal für die Wohnung, weil ich satt war, mir den Grundriss irgendwie mit Tollstock zu ermessen, da muss ich den verschieben und so, habe ich mir das eigentlich so teuer einfach mit so einem Laserding gekauft. Das schießt du dann raus und dann zeigt es dir an, wie weit das entfernt ist. Mega geil. Aber das wird auch super für so Offender. Die kriegen dann so ein Ding in der Hand und dann so wait! Und dann holen sie dieses Ding heraus und schießen auf dich mit diesem Laserding und dann 50 Meter. Okay. Und dann muss man da rumgehen. Weil wie ist das in der Praxis lösbar, dass du wirklich 50 Meter... Ich weiß es wirklich nicht. Keine Ahnung, du musst... Also ich glaube, ich wäre hinüber, wäre ich offender, weil ich habe ein ganz schlechtes Gefühl für Entfernungen und Distanzen und Quadratmeter und Entfernungen und Schritte. Und zählen Wände jetzt, wie zählen Wände, also angenommen, da ist ein Haus, wo das Kind drin wohnt und du gehst dann vorbei, zählen Wände dann so wie, ja, Wände zählen wie zehn Meter, eine Wand zählt wie zehn Meter. Ich glaube schon, ich glaube, das ist so ein Puffer. Ich glaube, Luft zählt eins zu eins, Beton drei zu eins, Wasser zwei zu eins. Und dann muss es halt immer ein bisschen... Im Wasser darf man näher dran ans Kind? Ja, weil es ja Träger ist. Das ist ein Loophole, ein mega geiles Loophole. Das ist ein Cheat. Ja, aber auf jeden Fall, das sind so Sachen, ich spiele Urlaubsorte gerne durch und dann will ich da einfach der krasseste sein. Der krasseste am Strand, der den besten Strandkorb kennt, der die beste Schaufel hat und ich bin lange nicht mehr im Urlaub. Die Antwort ist auch ein bisschen ... Die Prioritäten sind auch sehr kindlich. Ich habe einen amerikanischen Kumpel, ich habe meine Mutter Besuch an der Ostsee, schön, und dann habe ich da ein Foto gemacht
vom Strandkörbe überall, wohin
das Auge nur reicht, und
habe vorher noch mit einem amerikanischen
Kumpel darüber gesprochen, dass
wir in Deutschland Strandkörbe haben. Und er so, what?
Und dann habe ich ihm dieses Foto gezeigt, und er war,
er hat sich bis heute nicht einbekommen,
weil er dieses
Konzept Strandkörbe nicht kennt.
Und das ist mir schon aufgefallen, weil ich damals mal, als ich noch ganz klein war, in Chicago unterwegs war und dann hat mein Vater mich mitgenommen an den Strand da, an den Lake Michigan und da war auch schöner Strand, aber kein Strandkorb. Und ich als Kind war massiv verwirrt. Wo soll ich denn jetzt hin? Was soll das für ein Strand sein? Wo soll mein Körper hin? Wo soll das für ein Strand sein? Entschuldigen Sie bitte. Und es stellt sich heraus, haben die nicht dieses Konzept. War ein riesiges Problem im Zweiten Weltkrieg, als die Amerikaner in Frankreich landen wollten, in der Normandie. Die Deutschen kannten nicht so gut aus, hinter den Strandkörben zu sein. Die haben nicht damit gerechnet, dass alles voller Strandkorben steht, deswegen konnten die mit ihren Panzern nicht an den Strand fahren. Und hatten riesige Probleme, weil die nicht damit gerechnet haben. Bisschen wie die Amerikaner dann in Vietnam, haben sich die Deutschen auch in den Strandkörben versteckt und die sich genutzt, weil die wussten,
hey, wir haben einen Vorteil, die Amerikaner
kennen Strandkörbe nicht.
Aber ich finde, die Strandkörbe
ist schon nicht so schlecht, die Idee ist ja nicht so schlecht.
Du hast den ganzen Tag
wie so ein kleines Häuschen. Das kannst du drehen
und wenden, das ist ja alles
in einem, das ist ja Strandmuschel,
Liege,
Schirm in einem. Das ist schon nicht so schlecht, du kannst es drehen, du kannst es in die andere Richtung drehen, du kannst es neigen, du kannst dir so Fußdinger rausmachen, du kannst es schliessen, du kannst an den Strand gehen, um dann möglichst so zu leben, als wärst du nicht auf dem Strand und schön dein Sudoku in Dunkelheit in der Taschennappe zu machen. Dann kannst du am Rand so Dinger runterklappen, wo du da mal einen Becher draufstehen kannst. Und man kann die nachts abschliessen. Und das ist auch sehr deutsch, da kommt dann so ein großes Gitter rein, was man da so vorklemmt, und dann machst du unten einen Schlüssel rein, und dann hast du damit niemand in deinen Strandkorb kann, weil das ist ja dein Strandkorb für diese Woche. Und da sind ja die Wärze an drin, da sind ja die Gemälde drin, da sind ja das ganze Zahngäuble drin. Da packst du den Laptop rein erstmal, das ist das erste, was man macht, erstmal alles in diesen Strandkorb, alle Wertsachen in den Strandkorb. Router muss rein, nächstes Kabel, Kabeltrommel, schön vom Strandtuch. Entschuldigung, können wir hier kurz die Steckdose nutzen? Klar, aber das ist schon, Strandkörbe sind schon irgendwie faszinierend. Also ich verstehe da, warum es die gibt, aber ich verstehe auch, dass es sie nicht gibt. Ich verstehe auch die Amerikaner, die gesagt haben, nein, wir können einfach ein Handtuchkörner hinlegen und so. Ist ja auch nicht so, dass wir die Deutschen die auch, weil überall, wo wir uns sonst hinlegen mit Handtüchern und Drinks und die uns der schönen Natur erfrönen, ist ja zum Beispiel im Parks oder sowas, da haben wir jetzt ja auch keine Parkkörbe. Wir haben nur beschlossen, am Strand haben wir kleine Häuschen, wo man drin leben kann. Die kann man mieten, dann hat man die. Eigentlich nur Strandleute und Vögel haben einzelne kleine Häuser, in denen sie wohnen. Ja. Sind Vogelhäuser zu klein? Gute Frage. Und warum machen wir die hausförmig? Wir haben deren Häuser gesehen, das sind Nests. Die wollen nicht in den Wohlen. Die wollen in kleinen, runden Donuts wohnen. Die wollen nicht in hausförmigen Häusern wohnen. Die wollen kein Dach, die wollen die Sterne sehen. Mir gefällt diese leichte Anpassung, die wir denen dann doch geben. Es ist ein Haus, aber dann ist da ein Loch statt Natur und so ein Strich, so ein Stab, der so rauskommt, zum Draufsetzen. Weil wir haben schon mal Vögel gesehen, aber es wirkt so, als ob wir uns ganz kurz zu denen gedreht haben, wie Vögel aussehen und dann das Haus wieder gebaut haben, aber nach Erinnerung und nicht wie es echt schlägt. Und alles, was wir nicht wissen, ersetzen wir damit, wie wir leben. Ja, ja, Dach, Dach, Dach, Dach, Dach, Dach, Dach, Dach, Solarzell, Briefkasten, alles dabei, das ist so das kleine Ding. Aber vielleicht, also es gibt wahrscheinlich irgendwann den Moment, an dem man so einen Helm entwickeln kann, demontieren aufsetzt, dann können die sprechen und Vögel sagen, danke für die Häuser, die ihr uns baut, seit Hunderten von Jahren, aber die sind viel zu klein. Tiny. Viel zu klein. Tiny Häuser. Tiny Living, das ist bei euch ein Ding, ihr findet das cool, wir finden es scheiße. Wir hätten gerne so ein richtig großes Haus, mehrstöckig, schön Sofa, Whirlpool, Bar, Minibar, so ein Begehbarnschrank, alles wunderbar drin, aber ihr gebt uns immer diese kleinen.
Bauen wir denen kleine Häuschen mit Zimmeraufteilung auch?
Ja, ich glaube, du hast mehrere Zimmer.
Logger.
Es ist eine WG eigentlich.
Logger, WG, Maisonette, Giebel, alles oben drin. Wintergarten, Galerie, Atelier, alles drin. Das ist aber auch nicht schlecht. Gibt es bestimmt, oder? So jemand, der so richtig krasse Vogelhäuser baut, so eine richtige Villa, wo dann auch so ein kleiner Bademantel, so ein Bordeaux-Rotter Bademantel vorne hinten sitzt. Mit so gestecktem Namen. Meise. Und einfach der erste Vogel, der da ankommt, lebt einfach wie ein König. Meise. Und dann liest du ja auch so, dass du mit dem Bademantel Meise. Meise. Aber so ein Bademantel mit so grossen Ärmeln für die Flügel kann ich mir schon gut vorstellen. Riesige, riesige Flügel. So Poncho eher. So kleine Shampoosflaschen, so kleine Coca-Cola-Flaschen, kleiner Kühlschrank. Minibars kostet aber extra. Du machst den Kühlschrank auf und da ist einfach so ein riesiger Meisenknödel in dem Kühlschrank drin. Und die Meise so, oh yeah. So ein Ferrero Rocher oder so ein Riesending. Die Vögel lieben ja Kugeln. Also das könnte der Vogel auch sagen. Ist gar nicht nötig, unser Essen immer in riesigen Kugeln zu präsentieren. Wir haben einen Schnabel. Denkt doch mal bitte dran, einen Schnabel. Hey, habt ihr uns schon mal gesehen? Hallo, wir gucken wieder woanders hin. Wir sind nur, wir sind barely interessiert. Wir wollen wahrscheinlich noch größere Bälle haben, die sie essen wollen. Während die mit uns reden und sagen wollen, hallo, habt ihr gesehen, wie wir aussehen, ihr müsst uns nicht Kugeln bauen, sind wir dabei, Hundehütten zu bauen. Was mögen Hunde? Möglichst hohe Dächer, aber auch basically ein Haus. Was fällt uns denn eigentlich ein? Vor allem ist es ja wie so ein Comichaus, es ist ja wirklich wie so ein Snoopy-Comic-Haus, es ist ja eigentlich wie eine Karikatur eines Menschenhauses. Man sagt so, Tiere sind die Karikaturen von Menschen, also leben sie auch in solchen Häusern. Was wenn die Erde ein Vogelhaus ist für uns, eine andere Zivilisation? Ja, möglich. Aber und die Häuser von den Aliens sehen dann so aus wie die Erde, so ganz kugelig. Es ist einfach ein kleiner Planet. Die haben also dem quasi gesagt, so wollen die bestimmt leben und haben uns einen kleinen Planeten gebaut.
Und Menschen sind eigentlich gar nicht dazu gedacht, auf Planeten zu leben, sondern in Nestern.
Aber die haben gesagt, nee, wir leben auch auf einem Planeten. Kann sein, kann sein.
Aber wir haben uns angepasst vielleicht.
Wie gesagt, wir haben ja gesagt, jetzt durch die Pandemie sind viele wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse hinten rübergefallen,
hinterm Tisch, über den Tisch heruntergestürzt. Über den Tisch, hinten rein, in diese kleine Ritze, hinten rein, liegt jetzt da irgendwo. Schön, hinten bei den Steckerleisten, wo jeder weiß, was da ist, bleibt da. Da gibt es keine Hoffnung mehr. Der Tisch hat zwei Seiten, die Goldseite, wenn es vorne runterfällt, wird es sofort aufgehoben, wenn es hinten runterfällt, die Schattenseite, das war's. Wie The Dark Side of the Moon.
Und so werden die Sachen auf dem Schreibtisch miteinander reden, du willst nicht auf der Schattenseite leben.
Hier hinten ist der USB-Verteiler, das Ladekabel und die alte Steckerleiste.
Und der kleine Stift sagt, Papa, aber eines Tages möchte ich einmal den ganzen Tisch bereist haben.
Und er sagt, du gehst niemals an die Schattenseite.
Du bleibst hier vorne bei uns, hier ist die Maus, hier ist das Mauspad und hier ist das Glas.
Aber Papa, aber Papa! Nein, du gehst niemals dahin. Und dann ist nachts. Und dann geht der
Stift zum kleinen Radiergummi und sagt, hey, hey, Ratzefummel, Ratzefummel, ja, wach auf,
wach auf, wach auf. Ich habe gerade so geträumt, in einem kleinen Häuschen zu wohnen. Das aussieht wie ein kleiner Schreibtisch. Ja, war nur ein Traum. Pass auf, heute ist die Nacht gekommen. Wir gehen ans Ende des Tisches. Nein, aber du weisst doch, wir dürfen nicht auf die Schattenseite des Schreibtisches gehen. Willst du die ganze Zeit hier auf der hellen, langweiligen Seite sein? Hier haben wir alle schon gesehen, wir leben hier jeden Tag, wir werden barely benutzt. Du als Radiergummi? Man muss das letzte Mal richtig angefasst. Ja, er fasst mich gar nicht mehr an. Früher hat er mich selbst, wenn er nichts radieren wollte, mal immer wieder in die Hand genommen und mich gedrückt und vorne und hinten so die Säden zusammengedrückt. Willst du nicht auch wissen, wofür deine blaue Seite ist? Ja, natürlich, aber was passiert denn, wenn wir auf die Schattenseite fallen? Die Entwicklung der Technologie hat wirklich mich obsolet gemacht, du hast recht. Mich würde ja gar nicht vermissen, wenn ich hinten runterfallen würde. Frag mich mal, ich bin ein fucking Tintenkiller. Scheiss Tintenkiller, okay? Wann benutzt man ihn noch? Benutzt ein von heute noch Tintenkiller? Ich weiss es nicht. Und außerdem werde ich weggeworfen nach dreimal los und außerdem ist meine weisse Seite so nervig gelb geworden. Ich stinke auch. Tintenkiller stinken. Und irgendwann hat er auch seinen Füller verloren und angefangen mit dem Tintenkiller zu schreiben, mit der blauen Seite, die er dann aber nicht mehr killern konnte. Und dann war die auch nutzlos.
Machen wir es richtig ernst, kurz. Die blaue Seite ist nervig zu schreiben, die kratzt auf dem Papier, kratzt die durch. Ja, das ist einfach ein schlechterer Füller. Ich weiß nicht warum, das ist so ein Pay-off. Also die Welt, glaube ich, ist schon gerecht. Du hast ein Pay-off, der unzerstörbare Füller lässt sich dann aber auch schlechter schreiben. Also du musst gucken, will ich angenehme Schreibformen haben, aber dafür bin ich löschbar, oder will ich für immer schreiben, aber dafür kratze ich. Und dann mit dem Tintenkiller verschreiben. Ist ja auch so, du hast in der Klassenarbeit eine Chance gehabt. Ja, eine Chance. Und dann hast du gekillert, und dann hast du mit dem Killer draufgeschrieben, und dann hast du dich verschrieben und das gleiche wie er draufgeschrieben. Du hast Rousseau wieder völlig falsch geschrieben. Wie viele Os? Nicht mal im Ansatz. Und warum ist kein fucking O in Rousseau? A, E, A, O, U, E, A, ne, fuck it, nochmal neu. Aber dann kamen ja die Schülerinnen und Schüler, die nochmal dann die Geheimwaffe rausgezogen haben aus ihrem Socken. Tipp-X! Und Tipp-X kannst du so oft du willst über Tipp-Xen O-A-E-E-O, nee, nochmal neu, A-E-O-E-O-E-E. In Rousseau ist kein O, what the fuck? Und du kriegst die Schularbeit zurück und es ist einfach so ein zwei Zentimeter dicker Stapel an Tipp-X auf diesem einen Wort, wo du es dann so halb, ja der französische Typ halt irgendwie hingekriegt hast. Mr. Frenchman. Nee, aber das glaube ich ist mit meinem Impfpass passiert. Der ist nämlich irgendwo irgendeinem italienischen Stopp, den wir eingelegt haben, ist der hinter auf der Dark Side of the Table gefahren. Ja, weil du den immer so aus dem Fenster raushältst, während du fährst. Heureka! Nein, Stefan! Ich bin geimpft! Schaut!
Ich hab dir gesagt, du musst, erstens
fand ich, du warst in dem Urlaub viel zu überdramatisch.
Ja. Ständig, es war eine achtstündige
Autofahrt, siebeneinhalb Stunden davon,
bist du aus dem Verdeck rausgestiegen.
Wir standen im Stau.
Ja, weil man sieht auf Montagen, in Filmmontagen
sieht man diese Momente.
Ja, aber das ist ja nur ein kurzer Moment.
Von A nach B. Ja, aber die gehen einmal kurz raus, machen Wuuuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhu. Nein, weil die machen so Doku oder irgendwas, aber du musst nicht siebeneinhalb Stunden. Was ist mit deinem scheiß Doku? Wir standen im fucking Stau. Du standest da die ganze Zeit und hast, wuuuhu! Wir standen im fucking Stau am Brenner drei Stunden lang. Ja. Und dann hast du, warum hast du denn den Impfpass, was soll das für eine Montage sein? Völlig unzeitgemäß, wenn der Film in zwei Jahren rauskommt, die Leute denken sich, warum hat der denn den Impfpass in der Hand? Ende ist Ende der Pandemie, ich habe den Impfpass ausgehalten und habe abgerufen, wuuuhu! Film geht's nicht um Pandemie, das hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun. Auch das Orchester hatte grosse Probleme mit dem Soundtrack mitzukommen, weil dieser Moment über drei Stunden. Da können wir nicht mit harmonisieren, das ist eine Terz, das kriegen wir nicht hin. Da können nicht drei Stunden lang diese euphorische How to Train Your Dragon, ich setze mich auf den Drachenmusik machen, jeder kennt diesen Moment. Der ist knackig kurz. Wo die Geigen hochkommen. Der Harry Potter Hippogreif-Moment. Die können nicht drei Stunden lang bleiben. Nein, das geht nicht. Nein, das geht nicht. Das geht nicht. Deswegen, ich weiß nicht, wie es auf deinem YouTube-Kanal momentan aussieht, wann dieser Zusammenschnitt von deinem Urlaub kommt, aber sehr karg bis jetzt dein YouTube-Kanal. Einmal so ein Upload-Video, übrigens Leute,
hier wird es jede Woche ein Video kommen,
und ich freue mich, er ballert schon mal
den Subscribe-Button, und seitdem, seit acht
Jahren kam nichts mehr. Und dann kam erst direkt
dieses reißerische Video, ich höre auf,
mit dem Titel,
es geht so nicht weiter, und
so ein Tränen-Thumbnail
von mir, der hat vier Klicks,
aber eigentlich geht es nur darum, dass ich aufhöre zu rauchen. Und das nächste Video ist, ich rauche wieder. Ich rauche wieder. Und danach kam nicht mehr so viel. Eine geklaute Werbung aus 2006. Geklaute Werbung und dann sieben Entschuldigungsvideos für diverse Tweets oder aktuelle Drama, die du durchmacht hast. Und seitdem ist es leer. So, ich habe jedenfalls einen Impfpass, der ist viel on the dark side of the table. Und jeder kennt das ja, diese Probleme, wo man denkt, es ist die Welt vorbei. Ich wurde zweimal geimpft, ich kann es nicht mehr nachweisen. Das ist ein Dokument, was man nicht verlieren sollte. Jeder kennt diese Momente, aber dann gibt es halt immer mal wieder so Überraschungen im Leben. Problem stellt sich als bei weitem nicht so schlimm heraus, als du dachtest. Schüsste Momente, ja. Beste Momente. Ja. Ich habe mich eingestellt auf Bürokratie, ich habe mich auch aufgestellt, nochmal neu geimpft werden zu müssen. Ich habe mich darauf eingestellt, auf Bürokratie-Hassel mit Formularen durch die Welt zu rennen und zu sagen, ja, aber ich habe doch gerade bei der Dame und die Dame hat mich zu Ihnen geschickt und sie hat gesagt, ich habe mich bei Ihnen die Unterschrift holen, aber das geht nicht. So, stattdessen, ich musste zum Arzt gehen und die haben mir das unterschrieben mit neuen Impfpass gegeben. Gerade eben, ich habe es sogar noch vor der Aufnahme gerade geschafft. Und dann musstest du nicht alle Impfungen nochmal nehmen? Nee. Alle nochmal einmal zusammen? Nee, die haben sich das einfach gemerkt. Die haben sich das gemerkt, die haben sich das aufgeschrieben, die hatten sogar noch so Kleber von der Impfung, da sind mir wieder reingeklebt. Es war lächerlich, es war so einfach zu lösen,
dieser Sidequest.
Das war echt jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen so eine...
Ganz wenig Erfahrungspunkte bekommen. Ich bin extra in die Großstadt
gelaufen und habe mir so ein Team zusammengestellt
und gefragt, wer gerade den Quest auch machen muss und so.
Und dann habe ich jemanden gefunden,
der mir gesagt hat, ja komm, ich helfe dir kurz und dann bin ich einfach
zum Arzt und dann war es vorbei.
Man sagt ja, hättest du auch alleine machen können.
Ja, okay. C, U, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G, G,kt, dass es darum geht eigentlich, um gutes Leben. Es geht um am Strand zu sitzen? Nee, um gutes Leben. Und da merkt man, dass die Probleme, die man hat, eigentlich gar nicht so groß sind. Du kannst ein gutes Leben nur eine Woche im Jahr haben, oder was, wenn du im Urlaub bist? Ja. Das klingt ja furchtbar.
Ja, absolut schrecklich.
Du kannst so gute Zeit haben, wenn du im Urlaub mit sehr viel Geld verprasst?
What the fuck?
Den ganzen Tag Shrimps isst?
Nee, ich glaube, die Lektion ist eher, man merkt dann, wenn man so eine Woche am Strand ist, merkt man es auch zu viel.
Also man kann nicht nur Spaß haben im Leben.
Ich kann ja gar nicht gut abschalten, hört man auch häufig. Ja, ich gucke ja immer wieder aufs Handy. Immer wieder muss ich gucken, was auf Instagram los ist. Aber ich bin ja selber schuld. Poste ich ja auch Bilder von mir aus dem Urlaub und dann guckst du halt auch, ob die Likes haben oder nicht oder Werbung. Aber findest du Urlaube wirklich gut? Nee. Oder denkst du nicht auch immer nach drei Tagen, oh jetzt zurück? Das denke ich wirklich häufig. Ja. Nee, weil ich freue mich immer auf einen Rückflug oder Rückfahrt. Ja, aber es ist immer gut, weil du kannst dann, du sammelst ja sozusagen Alltag an. Also du hast ja immer so, das ist wie wenn du sagst, einmal am Tag kriegst du eine Süßigkeit. Aber wenn du im Urlaub bist, dann staut sich das auf. Und wenn du nach, so wie als hättest du einen Adventskalender und du bist während, du bist vom 8. bis zum 17. Dezember im Urlaub in Gran Canaria. Da gibt es kein Weihnachten und da gibt es keinen Adventskalender. Und wenn du nach Hause kommst, weißt du, ich kann jetzt die ganzen Türchen von dem Adventskalender aufmachen. Das heißt, du hast die Alltagseszenz sozusagen auf einmal zusammengeballt. Und das ist dann schon gut. Ich glaube, es lohnt sich, allein deswegen in Urlaub zu fahren, weil du Alltag ansammelst. Und dann auf einmal kannst du das dann alles wegessen. Ja, ein bisschen so Change of Perspective, ne? Nee, nee, gar nicht. Ein bisschen so... Nee, ich meine einfach, dass du mehr essen kannst. Ach so. Wenn du zurückkommst. Ja, man kann im Urlaub auch gut essen. Ach so, bist du nicht, weil du isst doch gern, du lebst doch auch über den Magen. Du freust dich immer sehr auf Essen. Nee, eigentlich nicht. Die meiste Zeit geht es in diesem Podcast darum, was du neu entdeckt hast. Ja, aber für mich ist Essen eher was, wirklich fast so eine Sklaverei so. Es ist fast schon zwanghaft, aber ich bin jetzt tatsächlich erfolgreich, vielen Dank, weggekommen. Und ich habe meinen Mate-Konsum von zwei Flaschen pro Tag auf eine Flasche pro Tag reduziert. Erbsen-Konsum? Erbsen immer noch voll dabei. Viel zu viel. Immer noch voll dabei. Ich bin, ich überlege eine riesige Erbse zu machen, also dass ich Erbsen. Wie so ein Meisenknödel. Ja genau, also dass ich alle Erbsen klein püriere und dann die alle in so einer Art Darm, also es ist ja kein Darm, wie so eine Erbsenhaut. In einer Erbsenhaut, die kriegt man ja auch irgendwie, kann man ja irgendwie simulieren. Und dann eine grosse Erbse und dann wirklich drei davon und wie so ein Eisbecher. Wie so ein Sternekoch anreichrichten. So ganz große, riesige, glänzende Erbsen auf so einem, oh, das ist mir aufwährend, ich habe wieder Olympia geschaut und da war rhythmische Sportgymnastik und die haben manchmal so Bälle. Oh ja. Und die sind so rund und glänzend und schön. Wie kriegen die sie so rund hin? Die sind so, also es sind aber die perfekte, das sind die Bälle, die, ich finde die so befriedigen, diese Bälle, weil die werfen die hoch, also die sind ja nicht hart. Die sind aus dem Boden in Kugeln, aber ohne Löcher. Die sind ganz perfekt rund. Und dann glänzen die so schön, aber die sind so leicht gummiartig. Das heißt, die haben so, die tun auch nicht weh, wenn man die auf nicht drauf fallen. Aber die sind, ich finde die so befriedigend, diese Bälle, ich will so einen Ball haben, so einen runden Gymnastikball. Diese kleinen, kennst du diese Bälle? Ich kenne die, ich kenne die. Ich finde die so befreundet, das ist wie so Anime, wie man das kennt, wenn man so eine Anime-Kugel zeichnen müsste. Das ist wirklich so ein Grafikprogramm, das erste Mal öffnest, und wenn du es lädst, dann hat der als Default 3D-Modell schon einfach mal eine Kugel. Und die ist perfekt, und die muss man dann noch bearbeiten, dass sie aussieht wie ein Pfirsich oder was man machen will. Und die ist perfekt. Und du denkst dir, nee, ich bin schon am Ziel. Ich nehme schon das 3D-Modell, Defaultball, ich bin schon am Ziel, ich will das so nehmen. Druck mir das. Ja, finde ich es fantastisch. Dann hast du diese Kugel, die hätte ich gerne für dich da. Ich meine, jede Sportart versucht sich ja zu verbessern. In der Formel 1 versuchst du jedes Jahr, bessere, schnellere Autos zu bauen. Die Bodengymnastik-Szene,
da ist der technologische Fortschritt
halt einfach reduziert auf diesen
einen Ball.
Und der wird halt jedes Jahr ein bisschen
besser. Und das sieht man bei der Olympiade
oder Olympia,
dass das ein Ball ist.
Jetzt beginnt die
Paralympics und jedes Mal freue ich mich auf das Neue, wie fair Paralympics sind. Fair? Fair. Ach so. Wie fair. F-A-I-R. Gibt es aber auch Reiten bei Paralympics? Und wer ist dann eingeschränkt? Das Fair? Oder beide? Oder eins von beiden? Ich weiß es nicht. Nee, aber jetzt mal ganz im Ernst. Spaß beiseite. Ja, weg jetzt damit. Weg mit diesem kreckigen Kackspass. Quatsch immer hier, braucht kein Mensch. Ist es nicht unfair, wenn Leute gegeneinander sprinten und die haben alle unterschiedliche Behinderungen? Naja, ich weiß nicht. Wer misst das? Ist ja die Frage, wie sich das ausbalanciert. Und dann haben die ja auch teilweise Prothesen. Und ist es nicht dann eher ein Wettkampf der Prothesenhersteller als der
Ja, da gibt es halt noch diese technologische
Aufrüstung, mit jedes Jahr bessere
Prothesen oder so. Vielleicht gibt es dann
irgendwann so einen Kipppunkt, wo die mit Prothesen besser werden.
Dann gibt es ja auch immer diese Diskussion, dass
Paralympics nicht so viel geguckt werden
und nicht so spannend. Aber ganz kurz,
wie viele Sportarten gibt es da? Gibt es da alle Sportarten?
Fast alle Sportarten auch, ja.
Ach krass, okay. Mein schon, aber wäre es nicht viel spannender, wenn man sagt, so Beschränkungen wie diese Prothesen die Körperteile ersetzen, gibt es nicht mehr. Die heben wir alle auf. Dass man eher den so Samuel-Koch artige, was der gerade hat, um das über die Häuser die Autos zu springen. Entschuldigung. Vielleicht falsch erinnert. Das ist der klassische Modeler-Effekt. Der ist über Häuser gesprungen. Und dann ist ein Haus zu hoch gewesen. Ich finde das keine schlechte Idee, aber jetzt gibt es auch gar nicht. Der hat doch diese geilen Känguru-Dinger. Diese tausend Meilen, diese hundert Millionen Meilen Stiefel.
Oder wie? Ich weiß nicht. Samuel Koch hatte doch diese, er hatte doch unter seinen Füßen sowieso Kängurusprunggelenke. Und dann konnte er richtig hochspringen. Wenn du das aber defaultmäßig in Leuten, die unten ein halbes Bein haben oder so dran baust, dann können die irre weit hochspringen und so. Also im Endeffekt viel weiter als jetzt so jemand von Echt Olympia, dem richtigen Olympia, dann ist es doch vielleicht spannender, wenn man da so einen crazy Technologiewettkampf rausmacht. Ja, finde ich keine schlechte Idee. Es gibt ja gerade momentan viele Skandale um diese ganzen Reitdisziplinen mit wie ist das, ist das in Ordnung und da wurde ein Pferd erschossen. Gab es den Skandal wirklich oder hat nur Aurel Merz einen Tweet rausgehauen? Ne, ich glaube, da gab es schon wirklich Skandal, aber es bedingt sich. Und es ist interessant, dass Pferde die einzigen Tiere sind, die eine Rolle in Olympia spielen. Du kannst ja auch sagen, lass uns Weitsprung mit Kängurus machen, da sitzen dann Leute auf Kängurus drauf, die halt möglichst Weitspringen oder so was oder Biber oder Dumbau oder irgendwie so was. Da würde ich eher sagen, lass uns diese Tiere komplett auslagern in eine eigene Olympiade. Tier-Olympiade. Dass die einfach so ein eigenes Ding machen, weil die können ja trainiert werden von Ländern, Nationen. Und dann machst du halt wirklich Känguru-Weitsprung. Und sag mir einen Menschen, gib mir einen Namen, der das nicht gucken würde. Wer das nicht anschaut. Ja. Wer nicht sagt, die Nation, ey gut, Känguru ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd, weil du kriegst, kannst du halt in Deutschland schickenicken. Und sitzt der Känguruführer in dem Korb vorne drin? Ja, du brauchst dann endlich richtig kleine Kinder. Kinder. Kinder führen die. Die in dem Beutel sind und die dann halt, ja, nicht viel machen, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Doch, die haben so, wie so die Zügel in der Hand. So eine Art Lenkrad. So eine Art Lenkrad. Und die führen den dann, das stimmt schon. Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Idee, das komplett auszulagern. Weil es ist natürlich albern, Pferde zu reiten. Und dann kriegt jemand eine Medaille und das Pferd wird erschossen als Tank. Das ist halt schon blöd. Aber dann einfach zu sagen, man lagert das komplett aus. Oder so Weitflug, es gibt ja zum Beispiel Taubenzucht als Wettkampf. Taubenzucht, und das ist ja wirklich so, kein Witz, ich habe das recherchiert, du züchtest die Tauben, wer am schnellsten fliegen kann, und Tauben merken sich ja immer, wo sie sind. Und dann fährst du alle Tauben auf Punkt A, fährst dann 100 Kilometer weit weg. Merken die sich immer, wo sie sind, da sind die auch wie wir, dass die mal nicht aufpassen. Ich glaube, die haben so zwei, drei Speicher-Slots und die müssen immer wieder geschrieben werden. Oder sind die mal nicht so achtsam? Nee, die sind immer achtsam. Achtsam. Und dann, auf 100 Kilometer fliegen die zurück zu dem Punkt und der Vogel, der als Erster ankommen hat, gewonnen. Und es ist wirklich so, steht im Wikipedia-Artikel, alle anderen werden gegessen. Gegessen? Alle anderen Tauben werden gegessen. Tauben werden so krass gegessen, ne? Habe ich bei Succession gesehen. Mit denen hält man so die Augen zu, ne?
Nee, man hält sich die Augen zu.
Nee, wirklich.
Man hält dem Kellner die Augen zu. Man hat so eine Decke auf dem Kopf.
Wirklich, man hat so eine Handtuch.
Ach, weil das so frischbar aussieht.
Ja, genau, und dann beißt du dir den Kopf ab und so.
Aber auch damit die Aromen innerhalb deines Körpers.
Und weil es auch illegal ist und das Leute nicht sehen sollen.
Aber ist das nicht noch auffälliger? Was ist denn der Typ da hinten? Pommes, Pommes Fritz. Pommes Fritz mit Ketchup. Aha. Ich hätte auch gerne Pommes Fritz. Dann zwingt er es dem Kellner zu und dann bringt er dir eine Taube. Oder der Kellner sagt, Entschuldigung, Sie haben jetzt zwar die Lasagne bestellt, aber wir wollen verhindern, dass alle denken, dass wenn sie die Decke haben, dann diese illegalen Tauben essen. Können Sie auch im Dunkeln die Decke nehmen, auch wenn sie nur Lasagne ist, einfach nur damit so ein bisschen, ne? Verstehen Sie, dass wenn jetzt die Polizei... Es ist das erste Date, ich meine, wir wollen uns ja auch... Ich verstehe das total, aber wissen Sie, wir müssen halt, Sie sind jetzt halt das Opferlamm. Sie müssen halt, hin und wieder brauchen wir einzeln, dass wenn die Polizei reinkommt.
Hätten wir das nicht schöner formulieren können? Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht gut, um mir jetzt, ich stelle Ihnen ja gefallen, aber mich als Opferlamm sozusagen. Ich bin jemand, ich spreche sehr klar mit Menschen. Ich mag es nicht, um den heißen Brei herumzureden. Sie sind Kellner, ist das nicht Ihr Job? Nein, ich mag es nicht.
Nee, klar, natürlich, ich bin in Höflichkeitsformeln geschult, aber ich mag es nicht, um das Thema herumzureden.
Ich bin jemand, der sagt klar heraus, was er denkt. Ich war ja mit einem Gastromenschen im Urlaub. Und das ist natürlich toll, wir waren auch immer natürlich gut essen, weil er uns auch gute Restaurants, die wir empfohlen, kleine Tipps gegeben hat und so. Und das war mega cool. Und dann, ich bin ja auch jemand, der immer den Kulissen, einen Blick hinter die Kulissen will. Und habe immer gefragt, das ist total das ist ja geil weil immer jemand hast mal zu fragen wie laufen die dinge eigentlich ab ich habe mich immer gefragt wir kriegen ersten gang und dann aufgegessen und dann kommen die kellnerin oder kellner und bringt den teller weg was passiert eigentlich dann hinter den kulissen sehr einfach zu erklären dann sie geht einfach in die küche und sagt die sind fertig und streicht dann durch und so und da gibt es einen Zettel.
Für jeden einzelnen Tisch.
Für jeden einzelnen Tisch, ja, ja.
Und dann weiss der Koch, ah, okay, und dann hat er wahrscheinlich schon angefangen, vielleicht die zweiten Gänge vorzubereiten oder er fängt dann erst an.
Und werden den ganzen Abend lang die Teller gewaschen oder werden alle am Ende des Abends gewaschen?
Ich glaube, die werden schon die ganze Zeit gewaschen. Es gibt auch Wäscher.
Das heißt, die Teller kommen von der Vorspeise, werden gewaschen und dann kriegst du vielleicht
das Dessert auf demselben Teller, den du
die Vorspeise hattest. Sehr unwahrscheinlich.
One in a million. Okay, aber wenn es
passiert, dann kann man sich freuen.
Ja, und dann
hat er
jedenfalls auch die Kellner und die Kellnerinnen
kritisiert, das war sehr interessant.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was ich jetzt sagen wollte. Der hat auf jeden Fall
immer uns gute Tipps gegeben,
was gerade hinter den Kulissen passiert. Stefan ist gerade in einer echten Krise. Oh Leute, ich glaube, da gibt es einen Upload bald auf dem YouTube-Kanal. Worüber haben wir gesprochen? Ich glaube, da gibt es bald über Tauben, dass Tauben gegessen werden und dass Tiere ihre eigene Olympiade haben sollen. Das weiss ich, da wollte ich dann auch zurückkommen drauf. Ja, ist okay, wir reden weit. Gut, Stefan hat sich dazu entschlossen, die Folge fortzusetzen. Vielen Dank. Klar, ist kein Problem. Ich bin so ein launiger Star, der so, jetzt werde ich mich ja auch nicht mehr weitermachen. Dann bin ich kurz rausgegangen, aber ich habe mich jetzt entschlossen, die Folge doch noch weiter aufzunehmen. Also Also wir konnten Stefan beruhigen und er ist wieder zurück in die Schule zurückgekehrt und er ist jetzt wieder da. Ja, ich bin jetzt wieder da. Lass einfach weitermachen und so tun, als wäre nichts gewesen. Hast du viel von diesen Brötchen, Cracker-Sticks gegessen? Grissini. Nee, die skipp ich immer. Die skippst du? Nee, weil es gab immer immer geilen Focaccia vorneweg, das ist viel besser. Das ist so auch, die geben einem geiles Focaccia und Grissini. Diese geben einem perfektes, gleich süsses, salziges, tolles, fluffiges Brot und viel zu harte Cracker, die nach nichts schmecken. Und da muss man sich immer, ist man immer erneut vor dieser Entscheidung gestellt und denkt immer, ja, ob wir jetzt, was ich nehme. Bei den italienischen Restaurants, in denen ich war, in den Superkrassen, in den du natürlich bist, da gab es immer schön Grissini und dann diesen Parmesantopf. Und ich habe eigentlich schon, bevor ich bestellt habe, mich sattgegessen an Grissini-Meets-Parmesantopf. Du musst ein Feuerzeug nehmen und es unter den Parmesantopf halten, bis der geschmolzen ist. Und dann so wie so ein Raclette. Und dann machst du so ein Fondue, dann ballerst du dann rein. Ah, toll. Was gibt es denn noch für Tiere, die man theoretisch in der Olympiade antreten lassen könnte? Ich denke an Biber. Du hast Dammbauaufgaben, du hast drei Lücken, da müssen dann Dämme reingebaut werden. Und wer es damals erst bricht, hat verloren. Und wer es als letztes bricht, kriegt die Goldmedaille. Und dann hast du die Biber richtig, die so meckern und untereinander. Mann, du Trottel hier, bau doch da den Stamm hin und so. Das fände ich gut. Was hältst du von Nashörnern, auf denen du reitest, gegen große Hindernisse? Und welches Nashorn das Hindernis so ein bisschen mit Diskus werfen, nur quasi, dass sie irgendwo gegenrennen müssen, und das schieben die dadurch an. Und je nachdem, wie weit das gedrückt wird, desto besser. Finde ich gut oder so ähnlich wie beim Reiten, wenn du über die Hindernisse drüber springst. Die Nashörner haben dieselben Hindernisse, müssen aber da durchbrechen. Also die dürfen gar nicht drüber springen. Holz, erstmal so ein großes Holztor, wie so ein Burgtor, eben nicht drüber springen. Genau. Wer drumrum geht, hat auch verloren. Wer drüber springt, hat sofort verloren,, der müssen durch. Also du hast Scharfschützen direkt auf den Stadiondächern, sondern die müssen da direkt durchbrechen. Aber ich denke auch an sowas wie Ameisenhaufen. Ameisenhaufen und du legst so einen Snickers hin und wessen Snickers als erstes aufgegessen ist, hat gewonnen. Ameisenhaufen. Und dann hast du halt so die Ameisendresseure aus verschiedenen Ländern. Wer am hungrigsten gedressiert hat, hat gewonnen. Du weißt aber vor dem Wettkampf noch nicht, was die da hinlegen. Also wenn du die jetzt voll auf Twigs und Bounty dressierst, ist riskant, und da kommt der strategische Aspekt ins Spiel, weil du weißt ja nicht, ob die da jetzt nicht eine Dose Pringles hinlegen und du dann so fuck und dann so close up auf die Ameisentrainerin, fuck. Hier sehen wir Kramaski, die komplett ihre strategischen Überlegungen gegen die Wand gefahren hat, sie zerreißt ihre Blätter. Jetzt wollen wir noch mal sehen, ob sie nicht vielleicht mehr Vertrauen in ihre kleinen krabbeligen Freunde haben würde. Wir gehen weiter zu Stefan Tietze mit dem Kommentar für die Ameisen. So, jetzt sehen wir hier die kleinen Ameisen. Man sieht auch schön die Formation, die sie gebaut haben. Das ist bei Frau Rita Kramatski ganz spannend. Die haben eine ganz spezielle Formation, wie man das hier sieht. Das hat sie ganz speziell gemacht. Sie kommen von allen Seiten an. Das ist nicht so wie bei Herrn Kramczyk aus Polen. Aber blockieren sie nicht damit die Logistikwege für die Abfuhr? Aber sie blockieren in gewisser Weise, das sind immer die Pros und cons, die man hier eingehen muss. Man muss immer, wenn man einen Weg geht, sicherlich ein paar Absprüche machen. Aber man sieht hier, der bulgarische Vertreter, da läuft es ganz anders. Die bilden eine große Linie und tragen nach und nach ab. Interessant. Wir sehen hier ein Close-Up auf den Ameisen. Man sieht auch die verschiedenen kleinen Trikots. Und auch die kleinen Sponsorings, die hier stattgefunden haben. Die kleinen Mini-Sponsorings, das sind wieder Mini. Ja, sehr gut, jetzt kurze Wasserpause, einmal kurz trinken, das ist ja ganz wichtig, auch bei den erhöhten Temperaturen hier in der Sahara. Oh, das Snickers ist weg, das Snickers von Frau Kampsch ist weg. Oh, wir gucken auf die Uhr, zwei Stunden achtunddreißig. Zwei Stunden achtunddreißig, wow. Wow, ich habe meiner Frau eigentlich gesagt, dass ich vor einer Stunde zu Hause bin. Nicht schlecht. Okay, ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Und alle, der ganze Ameisenhaufen wird jetzt aufs Podest gehoben. Und oh nein, er fällt runter. Oh nein, er fällt runter. Oh, die Ameisen vermischen sich. Sie fangen an, sich aufzufressen. Die Bulgarischen, die fressen die Deutschen. Die Schafschützen in Deckung. Immer Schafschützen auch bereit haben, dass, Verlierer werden alle erschossen. Ja besten Scharfschützen sind bei den Ameisenturnieren, weil die müssen am präzisesten. Ja, die müssen am präzisesten. Ja, ich würde das angucken. Die kann nur auf Ameisen. Wie würde mir das angucken? Ist eingefallen, was ich sagen wollte. Oh, danke. In der fucking Gastro. Deine Laune ist ja nicht zu ertragen. Okay, denn in der Gastro, wo man, habe ich mich gefragt, was passiert, habe ich ihn gefragt, wenn bei dir jetzt so ein Brad Pitt ins Restaurant kommt. Der will dann da essen, aber deine ganzen Tische sind voll. Also der macht so die Bewegung Hand in den Mund, wenn er reinkommt, oder wie? Brad Pitt sagt, so I would like to eat here, man. und er sagt, table is full, table is already besetzt, man. You know who I am, did you see, 12 years of slave. So, und dann habe ich gefragt, was macht man denn dann? Weil das ist ja ein gutes Restaurant, du willst einen anderen Kunden nicht vergraulen. Man will ja bei Brad Pitt da haben, natürlich. Und dann ist tatsächlich wohl im Waiters Handbuch steht drin, man kann dann an den Tisch gehen und sagen, pass auf, wir bezahlen euch das Essen, aber wenn die jetzt geht, ist der Abend für euch umsonst, wenn die genau jetzt aufsteht und geht. Ach cool. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, krass, was es noch so gibt für Dinge auf der Welt, die man noch nicht erlebt hat. Die Welt ist jetzt doch offen für Wunder. Aber vor allem, da würde ich mehr verhandeln, da würde ich sagen, nee, ich zahle das Essen, ich kriege noch 1000 Euro. Ich kriege noch 1000 Euro. Weil du hast jetzt die Verhandlungshoheit, du kannst verlangen, was du willst. Ich will zwei Autos haben, ich will zwei Hondas. Pass auf, ich habe gesehen, dass draußen Brad Pitt steht, also wahrscheinlich sind sie zu mir gekommen, um mir jetzt den Tisch wegzunehmen für Brad Pitt. Vor allem stell dir vor, da kommt nicht nur Brad Pitt, sondern 20 Stars gleichzeitig. So die Dreharbeiten für Grand Budapest Hotel oder so. Zehn A-List-Promis in irgendeinem Allgäuer Dorf irgendwo in Ungarn oder irgendwie sowas. Und dann kommen die da zu einem vollen Restaurant, einfach mal so Owen Wilson, Ralph Fiennes, kommen da alle an und dann so, ja, oh, wow, we'd like to dine here. We'd like to dine here. Wir müssen vorsichtig sein, wir müssen genau den Akzent treffen. Wir sind der perfekte Impressionist, deswegen sehr quasi Bill Hader-artige Impressionist, die mitbekommt. I'd like to dine here. Und dann müssen wir die Hälfte des Restaurants rausschmeißen. Und ja, ich meine, wenn die das nicht kriegen, was sie wollen, die Stars sind wütend. Ich meine, so ein Owen Wilson macht dann, ey, Guy, what's going on here, I wanna eat some Italian food. Ich hatte einen Kumpel dabei im Urlaub, jetzt leider Gottes, der sich nicht helfen konnte. Es war immer, wenn er Englisch gesprochen hat mit den Italienern, ein bisschen eine Parodie auf Italienisch. Also frechende... Was ja nicht verboten ist. Ich glaube, dass, also sag ich mal, politisch korrekt, gibt es ja gewisse Nationalitäten, die man nicht stereotyp imitieren darf. Italiener zum Glück nicht. Da kannst du machen, was du willst. Du kannst sagen, I want some meat, the ball! Kannst du einfach reingehen? Ja. Und vielleicht müssen wir diese Stelle in zwei Jahren rausschneiden, weil Italien teilen... Wir schneiden sie dann gerne raus. Ja, gerne. Kein Problem. Hier klafft eine Lücke. Sofort. Eine glückliche Lücke. Wir sind bereit, das rauszuhalten. Falls ihr jetzt euch denkt, warum habe ich die letzten zehn Minuten inhaltlich überhaupt nicht verstanden, weil wir... Ihr hört den Podcast im Jahre 2023. Und wir alle rassistischen Imitationen rausschneiden mussten. Und herzlichen Glückwunsch an Italien, denn ihr habt es geschafft. Und endlich ist euer Akzento. Aber noch sind wir nicht da. Si claro. Noch sind wir überhaupt nicht, wir Spanisch, noch sind wir überhaupt nicht da. Und er hat dann immer so gesagt, wenn er gefragt hat, irgendwie, I like the smoke, can, can you give me an Estre? Aber das ist schon, glaube ich, beleidigend, oder? Wie reagieren die Leute darauf? Nee, es war immer so ein bisschen so, can I help you? Also es kam der Italiener an, der italienische Kellner, hat dann gefragt, ob er uns helfen kann, und dann ist halt mein Kumpel irgendwie in diese Richtung gerutscht. Und es war auch Spaß. Es war subtiler, es war jetzt nicht ... Es war jetzt nicht ... Kennen Sie mich? It's me, can you give me the rest? Es war jetzt nicht so krass, aber es war jetzt auch nicht ... Alles weggepiept, es war jetzt ... Piep-Massaker an der Stelle hier. Es war jetzt auch nicht so das reinste, lupenreine Oxford-English. Ja. Und es war so subtil, dass die kennen nie ... Es war immer so ein ... Die haben so einen leichten Blick einem geschenkt, aber danach lief noch alles einigermaßen reibungslos. Wo ich aber auch dachte, ja, es ist schon irgendwie spannend. Das ist jetzt gar nicht so ... Es ist nicht alles rassistisch. Dafür sind die Italien dann doch einfach zu weiss wahrscheinlich und zu privilegiert, um da jetzt irgendwie so eine Racist-Nummer rauszumachen. Ja, man passt sich ja den Besprechpartner auch so ein bisschen an, apropos linguistische Feinheiten. Wir haben ja letzte Woche das riesige Problem aufgemacht mit Herbert, mit dem furchtbaren Witz, warum sich Weisert nicht in Weitraut, damit sie Herbert nicht Herbert. Viel Verwirrung, ich war in vielen ganz, ganz schrecklichen Seiten mit ganz, ganz furchtbaren Lokalwitzen, Dialektwitzen, ganz, ganz schrecklich. Ich habe aber viele Nachrichten bekommen davon, und zwar, es ist ein offenes Rätsel, und zwar wussten wir nicht, was das bedeutet, damit Herbert sie nicht herbehrt. Und ich habe das ganze Insel durchforstet, und wir wussten, wir dachten ja schon, okay, das wird wahrscheinlich irgendwas sexuell Schlüpfriges sein, wir kennen nur das Wort nicht. Es war genau das.
Genau, es war genau das. Es war genau das, das ist ein Dialekt. Und es gibt aber, ich glaube, aus gewissen österreichischen Teilen habe ich ein Wörterbuch gefunden, wo Bären für Küssen steht, also Bären mit Ä. Habe aber auch ganz viele Zuschriften bekommen von Leuten, die gesagt haben, ich kenne das Wort auch so. Aber alle haben es anders geschrieben. Also es ist teilweise B-I-R-E-N-B-I-H, B-E, B-E-H, B-E-A. Aber das ist ja normal, das ist bei diesen Sachen, die man nur aus Mundart kennt. Genau, und da habe ich mir auch gedacht, dieses Wort existiert rein in oraler Tradition, ist wahrscheinlich nirgendwo wirklich niedergeschrieben. Und auf Ähnliches kam auch Julian, der uns geschrieben hat, hier meine Lösungsvariante zum Waltraud-Witz, welche mich auf eine Art Geisterwort aufmerksam gemacht hat. Waltraud, die sind nicht in Waltraud, weil sie Herbert so zählt, Herbert, Beeren als Verb, korrekte Schreibweise unbekannt, kenne ich persönlich im Zusammenhang damit, dass eine Schraube oder Mutter sehr fest beziehungsweise gewaltsam angezogen wird. Beispiel, Klaus soll die Ratmutter nicht so anbeeren beziehungsweise festbeeren. Waltraud möchte also den Gang in den Wald vermeiden, ja, das kann man uns vorstellen. Eine Kürze-Recherche lässt mich jedoch vermuten, dass diese Ausdrucksweise dem Internet völlig unbekannt ist, daher kenne ich auch nicht die korrekte Schreibweise. Dies ist überraschend, der Konstruktion mit dem Wort von meinem Vater völlig selbstverständlich benutzt werden, und ich zeit meineslicht nicht gibt. Meine Mutter benutzt Wörter komplett falsch seit Jahren. Aber ich finde es auch irgendwie interessant, und das sind oft Dinge, die sie ständig sagen, oder die fallen mir ständig auf, aber zum Beispiel in meiner Familie, habe ich schon mal, glaube ich, erzählt, geht immer der Begriff um blanker Montag. Auf einen blanken Montag? Also wenn man etwas Besonderes macht, und das finde ich eigentlich geil, und das benutzt meine ganze Familie, der ganze mütterliche Teil meiner Familie benutzt diesen Teil, diesen Ausdruck. Auf einen blanken und dann Wochentag einfügen, normalen Wochentag einfügen. Freitag geht nicht, weil Freitag ist schon so wochenendlich. Aber so, wir gehen essen. Ihr wollt essen gehen auf einen blanken Montag? Ihr lasst es euch aber gut gehen. So auf einem etwas Besonderes machen, auf einem stinknormalen Arbeitstag. Ich finde das nicht so schlecht. Internet hat nichts gegeben. Es ist schlichtweg einfach nicht existent. Und es ist auch nicht so ein Dortmunder Ding. Auch da kennt das niemand. Es ist einfach nur, meine Oma und meine Mutter haben das irgendwie benutzt. Und dann wurde es jetzt einfach, es ist ein Thing. Und die benutzen das ständig. Auf einem blanken Montag gibt es nicht. Aber dass der Gesprächspartner auch immer das einigermaßen versteht. Ja, ist im Kontext. Ich glaube, wenn man direkt mit einer Person kommuniziert, kriegt man das auch viel besser mit, als wenn man es irgendwo liest im Internet oder so. Ja, ja. Die verstehen das alle, aber es ist schon immer so, und irgendwann habe ich das mal angesprochen, und alle Familien externen, also alle angeheirateten Familienmitglieder haben gesagt, ja, ja, macht keinen Sinn, danke, danke, danke. Seit Jahren feissen wir die Zäh feissen wir die Zähne zusammen. Es ist so angestaunt. Was heißt das? Irgendwann habe ich am Weihnachten mal gefragt, was heißt eigentlich dieser blanke und alle, oh ja, exact, what the fuck, das macht keinen Sinn, das gibt es nicht. Und dann ist es im Damm gebrochen an Erlösung, weil manchmal muss man Dinge ansprechen, die, das ist eigentlich interessant, schreibt uns mal, also dieser Herbert Scheiße kann ich nicht mehr lesen, meine DMs sind voll damit, weg, das Thema weg, nächstes Thema, was mich bald wieder nervt, aber was ich jetzt gerade spannend finde, schickt uns ein, was eure Eltern für Wörter benutzen, die es eigentlich schlicht nicht gibt, um die Sprache voranzutreiben. Und vor allem dann können wir ein Wörterbuch der verlorenen Wörter machen. Weil die werden ja wirklich verloren, also gerade viele Dialektbegriffe gehen ja schlicht verloren,
im Internet werden sie nicht aufgeschrieben, ngendwo stehen die. Nee, für das Internet müssen die ja auch einfach wahrscheinlich in einer grösseren Menge vorhanden sein, bis sich im Internet etwas fest ist. Und es müsste eine Einigung geben, wie man sie schreibt. Ich glaube, da diese Dialektworte einfach immer nur gesagt werden, weiß auch niemand, wie man sie wirklich schreibt. Also es gibt ja so gerade bayerisch, meine Mutter schreibt ja auch so manchmal Bücher in bayerischer Mundart und so und da kann man sich so zurechtlegen, wie man die ausdrücken würde, aber ich glaube, ganz einheitlich ist es auch nicht. Also du kannst ja unterschiedliche die Sachen schreiben. Aber dann machen wir das. Wir bringen quasi so ein Urban Dictionary raus, so ein Wörterbuch der vergessenen Sprache. Ja. Unsere Eltern sprechen. Aber jetzt, aber wir müssen auch das glaube ich abgrenzen, weil sowas wie der blanke Montag, das ist ja ein normales Wort, blank, das nur anders verwendet wird. Wir meinen jetzt nicht so krasse Mundart-Dialektsachen, die nur in eurem Bereich, sondern wirklich Individual-Dialekte von einzelnen Leuten oder von einzelnen Familien, oder wie ist es bei euch? Da sagst du ja die ganze Familie. Es sagen drei Leute aus der Familie, ja. Okay, also Kleinstdialekte. Das Wörterbuch der verlorenen Kleinstdialekte. Was sich auch immer sagt, was keinen Sinn ergibt, da bin ich ganz drüber hinweggekommen. Im Sinne von, das habe ich vergessen, vercheckt. Oh ja, okay. Und ich kriege das auch bei mir nicht raus. Es funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Er ist einfach falsch benutzt.
Nee, ich habe mal irgendwann gemerkt, als ich Brot erklärt habe in der Sendung, habe ich Brot erklärt und dann habe ich gesagt, Brot besteht aus zwei Teilen, und zwar der Kruste und dem Moos, dem Brotmoos.
Also das, wenn du so ein Brötchen aufschneidest, hast du ja noch so ein bisschen Moos.
Manche nehmen das dann raus und essen separat und so, aber halt so Fluffzeug, was in der Mitte hängt, was nicht Teil der Hälften ist. Und mein Bruder hat mich da mal angesprochen und meinte, du, nur wir sagen dazu Moos, das ist kein Wort, das sagt man nicht so. Wir haben halt als Brüder, als Kinder immer gesagt, das Moos, weil das war dann das Besondere an der Semmel bei uns. Aber da ist mir auch aufgefallen, ja, tatsächlich, man kommt ja nie auf die Idee, dass Wörter, die man kennt, man nur für sich kennt. Und dieses Moos war einfach nur ein reiner Kleinstdialekt, nur von unseren drei Brüdern. Kleinstdialekt, wie ist es schlecht. Ja, minimalst-Dialekt.org.
Ja, wird eine gute Seite.
Minimalst-Dialekt. Holt euch die und packt da die Werbung drauf, euer dummes Start-up oder so, mit irgendwie so komischen Tabletten, die man in Wasser wirft.
Ja, oder so Schachbretter, wo er, das kriege ich auch immer geschickt, die immer, nee, die wohnen Magnet drin sind und dann schiebst du das A.
Ja, oder die dir so die Züge anzeigen und dann sagst du, ich würde gerne nachspielen, Bobby Fischer gegen Checkoff. Und dann kannst du damit so leuchten, so wie wenn ein Klavier leuchtet, dann kannst du etwas nachspielen. Lasst es sein. Lasst es einfach sein, Leute. Es muss nicht sein. Es muss nicht sein. Aber jetzt du bist zurück, du stehst wieder mitten im Leben. Ja, merkt man, mein Gehirn funktioniert einwandfrei, ich bin komplett hellwach schon. Du hast schöne Fotos gemacht, schöne Erinnerungen. Man kann ja eigentlich sagen, dass der Urlaub, die tatsächliche Zeit des Urlaubs nur ein kleiner Teil des Urlaubs ist. Der Rest findet in Erinnerung statt. Man denkt gern zurück. Ich bin auch nicht gut darin gewesen, lange Zeit einfach nur zu urlauben und sagen, das ist für mich und so, weil ich war, gibt es auch so, ich war auch oft ein Mensch, der sagte, ja, ich muss das für Instagram jetzt hier alles
festhalten und möglichst allen zeigen, was für eine tolle Zeit ich habe und so, aber das ist auch ein Prozess in unserer Generation, davon wegzukommen und ich finde es gut, dass Leute davon
wegkommen und ich habe es, glaube ich, auch geschafft, dass man einfach das für sich macht, achtsam ist, nicht immer, und dann auch diese Fotos, die man die ganze Zeit
macht für das scheiß Handy, das ist auch so dumm einfach, weil das guckt sich niemand mehr an. Ja, ich habe den Vorteil, meine Handykamera ist kaputt, also alle Fotos, die ich mache, sehen absolut grauenvoll auf, und ich schäme mich wirklich dafür, ich schäme mich, weil ich habe ein neues Kabel gebraucht für meine externe Festplatte, und bevor ich da zu dem Elektronikmarkt gegangen bin, habe ich ein Foto gemacht von der Buchse, damit ich genau weiß, welches Kabel ich kaufe. Damit du Haar genau weiss, welches Kabel du kaufe. Und dann habe ich es nicht gefunden und dann bin ich auch zu so einer Mitarbeiter gegangen und habe gesagt, Entschuldigung, ich bräuchte ein Kabel mit genau dem Anschluss. Und meine Kamera ist ja mittlerweile... Das wäre so gut, wenn man zum Frisörger ist und sagt, ich hätte gerne diese Frisur. Und dann so, okay. Meine Kamera steht nicht mehr scharf, ich habe schwarze Flecken im Bild, alles grauenvoll. Also das war das hässlichste Bild, das jemals ein Mensch einem anderen Menschen gezeigt hat. Ich habe gesagt, ich brauche dafür ein Kabel. Und er denkt sich auch wahrscheinlich, du kannst so nicht mit Technik umgeben, auf allen Ebenen. Stimmt, das Kabel ist dein Problem. Der müsste mich eigentlich zur Seite nehmen. Pass auf, vergiss das Kabel, du hast gerade ganz, ganz andere Probleme. Ganz, ganz andere Probleme. Löcher im T-Shirt, Kabel, Löcher in der Kamera, alles kaputt ist direkt drunter. Das funktioniert nicht. Aber der Vorteil ist, ich mache keine Fotos mehr. Und du laufst achtsam durch die Welt. Ich lauf achtsam durch die Welt. Ja, geht. Geht. Nee, du bist auch nicht so achtsam. Nee, ich bin überhaupt nicht achtsam. Du bist auch eher in deinem Kopf zu Hause. Ich trage auch, glaube ich, 90 Prozent des Tages Kopfhörer, wirklich, 90 Prozent, fast den ganzen Tag. Also du versuchst sogar, du bist das Gegenteil von achtsam, du versuchst die Welt auszublenden. Ich glaube, wenn man das wirklich mal timen würde, ich glaube wirklich, ich bin bei 80, 90 Prozent. Wenn ich zu Hause bin, trage ich Kopfhörer, wenn ich rausgehe, trage ich Kopfhörer, immer. Immer. Wirklich immer. Ich kriege die echte Welt gar nicht mehr mit. Also die, was heißt echte Welt, aber halt wenn irgendjemand pfeifen würde oder so, das würde ich nicht mitbekommen. Oder Hey Florentin ruft, Hey Florentin, du wirst nicht mitbekommen. Würde ich nicht mitbekommen. Auch nicht so schlimm. Aber ich verstehe, was du meinst. Diese Dauerbeschallung und dieses,
aber ist es auch ein bisschen keine Stille mehr ertragen können?
Ja, es gibt halt was Besseres als Stille.
Kannst du halt irgendwie so einen Mark-Marin-Podcast hören?
Ist halt besser als Stille.
Ich denke mir auch, das ist auch der Claim von seinem Podcast.
Besser als Stille.
Das ist der Claim dieses Podcasts.
Besser als nichts.
Besser als Mark Marins.
Besser als Mark Marins, besser als Stille.
Mark Marins ist besser als das Podcast, ist besser als Stille. Ja, das ist so ein Schere-Stein-Papier-System, das schwer zu durchblicken ist. Ja, genau. Aber ich sehe, was du meinst. Ich habe immer auch was im Hintergrund laufen, so im Fernsehen oder auf den Boxen, wenn ich zu Hause bin. Jetzt nicht über den Kopfhörer, aber man hat schon irgendwie, man denkt irgendwie, es gibt zu viele Möglichkeiten gerade, als dass man gerade stille aushalten sollte. Man kann ja irgendwie immer was laufen lassen und so. Dann läuft halt so eine schwarze Lochdoku, die viel zu kompliziert ist, schon um sie achtsam zu schauen, läuft dann im Hintergrund, während man irgendwas anderes macht. Aber ich denke, irgendwas wird ja hängenbleiben im Hinterkopf. Aber jetzt mal eine kurze Frage. Eingenommen, du kriegst Besuch, jemand kündigt sich an, ey, ich komme um drei. Horrortag. Du willst aber ja nicht als Gastgeber, als Empfänger des Besuchs nicht so wirken, als würdest du dich super auf den Besuch vorbereiten. Als hättest du, natürlich, du räumst extra auf, du guckst, dass alles gut riecht, dass alles gut ist, dass die peinlichen Sachen versteckt sind, aber du willst ja nicht, dass es so wirkt. Und dann ist ja die Frage, du musst ja irgendeine Situation konstruieren, bei der du erwischt wirst, wenn die Person kommt. Weil du kannst ja nicht einfach nur still im Raum sitzen, Ding Dong und du machst auf und du sitzt einfach da, sondern du musst gerade was machen. Das heißt, du hast vielleicht ein Buch aufgeschlagen auf dem Schreibtisch oder eine Doku läuft. Wie präzise konstruierst du diese Momente und was sind deine Go-To-Medien, die du da aufschlägst? Ja, ich mache dann oft den Fernseher an und dann steht da und dann mache ich eine Müsli-Schale, ganz wenig Müsli rein, ganz wenig Milch rein und kipp sie aus auf der Couch. So, und dann nehme ich mir,
warte ich auf dem, also nehme ich, gehe ich in die Küche und nehme ganz viele Küchentücher.
Und wenn der Besuch klingelt,
dann habe ich quasi,
sehe ich so aus, als ob ich gerade diesen Fleck weggemacht hätte.
Also du gehst dann auch in die Tür und hast dann so ein Knäuel-Küchentücher in der Hand.
Ich gebe auch den Knäuel-Küchentücher.
Ach, komm rein, du, ich tu die Schuhe aus.
Du glaubst, ich was gerade, und er sagt, schon wieder es schon wieder? Was machst du denn immer mit dem Müsli? Aber was läuft denn bis 18 Uhr, was ist denn jetzt Müsli? Ach so, ja. Und was läuft im Fernsehen? Was läuft auf dem Fernsehen? Sport. Sport, einfach generischer Sport. Eurosport. Eurosport. Most generic Nashorn-Weitsprung, ja. Most generic stuff. Ja. Und dann freust du dich aber auch, wenn die Person im genau richtigen Moment kommt, wo dann gerade keine Werbung läuft, weil Werbung ist immer nervig. Ja. Eigentlich wäre es clever natürlich, was kulturell anspruchsvoller anzumachen, also irgendwie wie die Schwarze Loch-Doku oder sowas. Ja. Und du hast dann so eine Kindermagnettafel, die du dir noch irgendwie rausgekramt hast, wo du selber so eine Gleichung draufschreibst.
Oh ja, genau.
Das heißt, du knurbelst mit.
Und auf dem Tisch vor dem Fernseher steht noch ein Block, wo du gerade so Notizen gemacht hast. Ich mache das gerne, wenn ich eine Doku gucke, ich schreibe mir kurz was auf, einfach so ein paar Begriffe.
Und liegt ein Buch zur Doku zum Beispiel, also so was wie Stephen Hawking, gekrümmte Zeit, gekrümmter Raum, liegt dann auch auf so einem Tisch und ich schlag so nach. Und bin so angestrengt, so ruhig da drin und es kleben so zwei Generic Post-its auf Seiten. Und wenn die Person kommt, dann auch so sagen, Entschuldige die Unordnung. Sorry, die Unordnung. Egal habe, egal, ich räume es kurz weg. Ich räume es kurz weg.
Hebst es so hoch, dass der Titel genau gut gesehen werden kann.
Stephen Hawking und es ist einfach, also, egal, weg mit dem Kram hier.
Was hast du da gemacht?
Was hast du hier gemacht?
Ach, ich schaue gerade eine Doku über Schwarze.
Ich weiß gar nicht, aber...
Was rechnest du denn da aus auf dem Blog?
Hm?
Was rechnest du denn da aus auf dem Black-Blog?
Ach nee, ich habe nur kurz überschlagen wegen der Anziehungskraft und wie das genau ist mit der Zeitzerrung. Das geht für mich nicht auf. Und irgendwie dachte ich, es geht nicht auf, ich habe es dann mal kurz durchgerechnet, aber ja, der Hawking hat schon einen Punkt. Also das ist schon... Ich weiß gar nicht, dass du so begabt bist, was für Physik... Das ist ja ganz einfach so, du guckst da einfach nur die Formeln und setzt das ein und schaust dann auch mit der Planck'schen Konstante, wie das alles funktioniert. Sogar Post-its in dem Buch drin. Ach ja, ich habe halt so ein schlechtes Gedichtnis. Zeig mal, wo hast du denn die Post-its in dem Buch drin? Also hier einmal auf Seite 138. Das ist die Riemann-Hypothese. Also arbeite ich halt gerade dran, irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, Millennium-Probleme und so. Und dann der zweite Post zweite Pause ist hinten im Glossar. Ja, das ist genau, nochmal hier bei den Gutscheinen. Da wollte ich mir noch ein neues Buch holen, noch das nächste, den nächsten Teil. Dann kriege ich dann hier 15% Rabatt. Und willst du dich mal um das Problem mit dem Müsli? Ach ja, ich dussel, ich bin dann so in Gedanken. Aber für eine gute Idee, dass immer, wenn jemand klingt. Wie oft müsste man das machen, bis die Person es wirklich bemerkt, dass man immer was aufputzt, gerade wenn die Person kommt und immer so ein Mob in der Hand oder so ein Lappen oder irgendwie so das T-Shirt offensichtlich gerade neu gewaschen oder muss sich kurz ausziehen. Aber das stimmt, ich mache das nie. Meine Wohnung sieht immer so aus, als ob ich die Personen erwarte und dann auch nichts gemacht habe bis zu dem Zeitpunkt. Als ob ich einfach mit wachen Augen auf der Couch gesessen hätte, ohne Buch, ohne Handy, nichts in der Hand, einfach aufgestanden wäre und dann den Besuch erwartet habe. Das ist auch so, wenn der Besuch da ist und man sitzt dann zusammen und unterhält sich und dann sagt die Person, ich gehe kurz aufs Klo und dann ist die Frage, was macht man in der Zeit? Weil du kannst ja nicht einfach nur still da sitzen und warten. Ja, du bist so wie so Stand-by. Ja, Stand-by. Und die Person kommt zurück und du willst ja nicht einfach in die Luft starrend. So, du hast jetzt einfach ein paar Minuten nichts getan, sondern du musst dann so Ali-Mässig. Und ich glaube, dafür wurden Magazine erfunden. Ich glaube, für genau diese Momente wurden Magazine erfunden, weil du hast dann so die Cosmopolitan rumliegen und du blätterst dann. Ja, oder Coffee-Table-Books. Ja, genau. Ja, das stimmt. Weil Coffee-Table-Books, die schaut man sich ja auch. Ich habe so viele rumliegen, weil ich das gelernt habe, aus Wohnungen, die ich schick finde, dass man die hat. Da habe ich sehr viele gekauft. Über die Jahre, weil das auch so ein gutes Mitbringsel ist.
Ja, riesig sperrig, teuer, perfektes Mitbringsel, super. Riesig sperrig, passendlichen Koffer, perfekt so. Das bringst du dir mit aus Brooklyn. Wenn du zwölf Stunden fliegst, hast du das dann sperrig in der Tüte im Handgepäck rumliegen.
Das ist perfekt so, mega, mega gutes Mitbringsel. Und dann liest du es zu Hause hin und liest es nie. Nee. Aber das sind doch so Momente, wo man es dann lesen könnte. Genau, wo man dann zumindest reinguckt, ja. Die Dinge haben schon Sinn, wenn du frisch in eine Wohnung ziehst, denkst du dir, ah, ich brauche nicht viel, minimalistisch, aber Stück für Stück merkt man nie, die Dinge haben schon einen Zweck, einen sozialen Zweck, dass man das kurz mal reinguckt. Ich komme halt von hinten an die Dinge heran. Du kaufst sie erst und merkst dann, wofür sie gut sind. Ja. Okay, bei mir ist es andersrum. Ich merke, oh, ich hätte jetzt gerne so was und besorg es mir dann. Niemand denkt, ich hätte jetzt gerne einen Coffee Table Book. Ich hätte jetzt gerne was, was ich machen kann, damit es nicht so bescheuert aussieht, dass ich einfach gar nichts mache. Rubik's Cube. Oder halt diese Stifte, wo du dein Gesicht so reindrückst. Verstehst du, nice, verstehst du Klos, wo Magazine drauf liegen? Oben drauf! Verstehst du, nein, nein, so Klos, in denen Sudoku-Hefte liegen oder Comics oder so. Verstehst du das? Ich verstehe es nicht. Zeitungen. Jetzt ein anderer Kumpel von mir hat einen Nintendo Gameboy bei sich eben an der Wand Da kann man die nehmen, beim Stuhlgang zum Beispiel. Und da spielt man Tetris dann. I don't fucking get it. I don't get it. Ja, ich habe ja das perfekte Buch gefunden, und zwar Hundert Mythen, nee, ich glaube irgendwie so Die griechische Mythologie in der Kunst, hundert Bilder von Lars Larsson, ganz einfach zu merken, Lars Larsson und das ist ein Reklambuch und auf der einen Seite ist immer das Bild und auf der anderen Seite ist nur eine Seite die Beschreibung des Bildes, welche Götter Mars trifft irgendjemanden, hat sein Schwert verloren, irgendwas und das ist super, weil das kannst du genau lesen. Das war auchen. War auch kein großes Problem. Schwert verloren ist ein bisschen wie Impfpass. Nee, aber irgendwie Pan hat sich im Schilf verloren und spielt seine Flöte. Welcher Pan? Der Pan, der Original Pan. Der Pan spielt Pan. Der OG Pan, genau. Und dann geht es halt einmal so durch die Zeit. So geht los in der Antike, dann Mittelalter und dann Neuzeit und so, und kannst du dich dann so durchblättern. Ist ideal. Von Reklam. Reklam, für Fortgeschrittene gibt es auch noch die Bibel in der Kunst, auch 100. Wir haben übrigens vielen, vielen Dank an den Reklamverlag, unbezahlte Werbung, bisschen bezahlte Werbung, aber ohne dass wir was dafür können. Wir haben, die haben uns was geschenkt. Echt? Die haben uns nämlich die originalen Notizbücher mit dem roten Punkt geschenkt. Aber wie geschenkt, wo sind die? Haben wir nicht, hab ich es geträumt? Haben wir nicht ein Bild bekommen? Wir haben ein Bildgeschickt bekommen, wie die angekommen sind in Berlin bei unserem Office. Ach so, ja stimmt. Aber das wird nicht an uns weitergeleitet. Doch, glaub schon. Ich bin ja so großer Fan von diesen Reklamnotizbüchern. Ich auch. Weil da passt einfach alles zusammen, um es kurz zu machen. Die haben den Red Dot Design Award gefunden. Und vorne auf Notizbuch, wo man ja Dinge aufnimmt, steht REC wie auf allen anderen Reklambüchern für Reklam. Aber REC heißt auch Rekord und daneben ist der rote Punkt vom Red Dot Design Award und der rote Punkt steht auch auf Kassettenrekordern für Aufnahme, REC, Reklam, Rekord, roter Punkt, REC. Da passt alles zusammen. Da passt alles zusammen. Haben die aber für diese Idee, die Red Dot Design Award bekommen, nein. Nee, das geht nicht. Weil dann würde die Welt in sich zusammenfallen. Das kann schon sein. Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert, aber ganz grossartig. Und ja, ist ein Stift mit dabei, Schuber, grossartig, das ist so leicht. Schuber. Uns wird nur so ein Bild vorgehalten und wir machen Werbung dafür. Schuber. Schuber, ja. Das sagt man auch nicht. Doch, Schuber ist ganz wichtig. Nein, das sagst du in deinem kleinen Mini-Dialekt. Nein, nein, nein, du hast schön die ganze, alle Staffeln Seinfeld im Pappschuber. Sag mal nicht. Dann schiebst du die so rein. Hat man nicht. Gibt's nicht. Gut, werden wir sehen. Wir freuen uns auf eure Einsendungen für die Kleinstdialekte.
Wünschen euch eine fantastische Woche. Haut rein,
wir sehen uns. Bis dahin sind wir
weg. Wir sind weg und abgehoben
und wir freuen uns schon auf
nächste Woche. Macht's gut.
Macht's gut.
So ist Burr-Brush.